199 amendements discutés soixante et une
heure de débats le projet de loi asile
et immigration a été adoptée en première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale est 2
128 députés pour 139 contre le texte a
fait l'objet de vives discussions au
sein même de la majorité bon sens
nicolas kirillovitch bonsoir de la
rédaction de tv 78 parmi les votants
bien sûr les députés yvelinois quelle a
été leur vote alors premières
informations déjà il ya douze députés
dans le département des yvelines
trois seulement étaient absents pour
pour ce vote c'est plutôt un bon ratio
comparé à la tendance nationale parmi
parmi les absents on remarque évidemment
là la non venue de marie le bec député
de la république en marge de la 4ème
circonscription 4e circonscription des
yvelines michel devaux couleurs du modem
qui appartient elle aussi à la majorité
et michel vial et c'est un peu différent
puisque c'est le seul député les
républicains du département beaucoup de
députés absents ont justifié la non
venue à cause des vacances scolaires
peut-être aussi parce que certains
étaient gênés d'afficher leurs
convictions leurs positions réserves par
rapport à ce texte vous en parliez
nicolet les des parlementaires qui n'ont
pas souhaité voté pour ce texte c'est le
cas notamment d'une députée vaudoise
oui il s'agit de florence grange du
député de la 12e circonscription des
yvelines membres de la république en
marche et qui fait donc partie des
abstentionnistes sur ce texte
ils ne sont que 14 parmi les 12 212
votants de la majorité florence granger
ancienne directrice d'une agence pôle
emploi s'est notamment opposé au
placement des mineurs en centre de
rétention elle s'est exprimée d'ailleurs
sur le sujet samedi à l'assemblée on les
écoute
la france fait partie des trois pays
européens qui ont pas se placer le plus
grand nombre de mineurs en rétention
administrative
alors même que de nombreuses solutions
alternatives à l'enfermement existe il
n'est pas possible de construire un seul
être un seul pays et une europe forte
avec pour exemple dans les yeux
d'enfants qui seront aussi les femmes et
les hommes du monde de demain des
barrières appréhendé dès le plus jeune
âge
trois députés
zibeline watts ans florence granger qui
s'abstient qu'en est il des autres
parlementaires nicolas vous allez le
voir sur l'écran l'ensemble des autres
députés ont voté pour ce texte en
première lecture que ce soit les élus de
la république en marche ou du modem ils
sont huit au total
à noter pour l'anecdote qu aurore bergé
didier baichère n'ont pas été
enregistrés officiellement parmi les
pour à cause d'un problème technique à
l'assemblée au moment du vote mais ils
sont ils ont soutenu largement ce texte
un texte équilibré selon jean-noël
barrot élus modem de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
il en veut pour preuve l'assouplissement
du délit de solidarité on l'écouté je
crois qu'un certain nombre d'ajustements
très intéressant et très importants ont
été apportés à cette loi par l'assemblée
je pense notamment à
à la fin du délit de solidarité
désormais lorsque des personnes et
escorte dans leurs véhicules des
personnes en détresse vers un hôpital
par exemple elles ne pourront plus être
inquiété alors il ya une question qui
demeure tout de même nicolas à propos
d'un éventuel début de fracture au sein
de la majorité est ce le retour des
frondeurs version en marche
en effet c'est la première fois qu'un
texte est autant débattu au sein de la
majorité
qu'autant de craintes et réticences sont
exprimées par les députés depuis un an
rien d'affolant cependant pour nadia et
député de la 11e circonscription est des
yvelines pour elle c'est normal
finalement qu'il y ait des divergences
sur un tel sujet effectivement il y
avait un vrai débat parfois un peu un
peu musclée au sein de la majorité parce
que et on nous avons des personnes de
conviction parce que nous avons des
personnes qui sont engagées depuis des
années sur ces sujets là et évidemment
ils expriment leur point de vue qui est
qui forcément ne ne va pas le point de
vue d'autres d'autres députés de la
majorité
on ne peut donc pas parler pour le
moment de fronde comme au temps de
françois hollande mais des avis qui
s'expriment simplement dans un débat
démocratique on verra malgré tout si ce
sera toujours le cas après le vote du
sénat en juin le texte sera sûrement
amendée par la droite et les discussions
devrait alors reprendre ardemment au
sein de la majorité de la république en
main merci nicolas pour ces précisions